question bonjour est ce que vous vous
trouvez devant l'autel de versailles à
quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à ce
que les policiers sont au rendez vous
oui ils sont tout à fait au rendez vous
puisque de nombreux effets qui sont
arrivés au fur et à mesure à partir de
13 heures donc il y à l'ats la police
judiciaire de versailles les effectifs
de sécurité publique de versailles
les motards de la police des yvelines la
police aux frontières ils sont venus en
moto en vélo à pied il ya là derrière
moi il ya plus d'une centaine de
policiers qui s'apprête à couvert une
action vers 13h30 dont nous vous en
reparlerons évidemment après qu'elle ait
eu lieu
en tout cas cette action d'aujourd'hui
est organisé par unité sgp police il se
trouve que c'est une action de plus un
cadre les policiers se font
particulièrement entendre depuis jeudi
dernier date des rencontres entre les
syndicats de police et christophe
castaner dès jeudi soir il a eu des
déposes de menottes dans de nombreux
commissariats organisé par unité sgp
police ensuite dès le lendemain une
action autour de l'arc de triomphe
organisée par les syndicats alliance et
unsa avec un défilé jusqu'à la place
beauvau encore samedi un autre un autre
rassemblement à l'arc de triomphe et
hier comme vous le disait à l'esplanade
du trocadéro
donc les policiers évidemment conteste
les propos de christophe castaner du
ministre concernant notamment la
présomption d'innocence
en cas de soupçon de racisme et bien
évidemment il souhaite ne pas être
suspendu il souhaite que ne l'est que
s'il ya des des faits avérés et puis il
y a également la question de la
suppression du contrôle de tête donc une
des méthodes d'interpellation pour les
policiers
nous avons rencontré les policiers de
terrain et bien les propos de christophe
castaner sont la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase
et au moment où je vous parle il y à
exhaler il y a également des actions
dans tous les commissariats du 93 et à
créteil
merci beaucoup katia technique